[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
opération barkhane quel bilan
une force de 3 à 5000 soldats 6 ou 7
avions de chasse et une vingtaine
d'hélicoptères
l'opération militaire d'arcane a été
menée par les armées françaises dans
plusieurs pays du Sahel entre 2014 et
2022 son objectif était de lutter contre
des groupes terroristes djihadistes
affiliés à Al-Qaïda ou à l'état
islamique le rapport fait au nom de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées par Pascal
Alizard Olivier cigolotti et Marie
Arlette Carlotti vise à faire un bilan
de cette opération
la Commission souligne le caractère
singulier de l'opération barkhane et les
multiples difficultés auxquelles elle a
dû faire face
à l'opération militaire proprement dite
s’ajoutait le renforcement de la
capacité militaire des États concernés
le retour de l'État et de
l'administration sur tous les
territoires ainsi que l'aide au
développement le rapport souligne
d'abord les obstacles logistiques et
opérationnels majeurs auxquels ont été
confrontés les forces françaises sur le
terrain parmi ceux-ci la présence de
groupes terroristes se caractérisant par
leur capacité à se régénérer
l'instrumentalisation des tensions
interethniques préexistantes le
recrutement de combattants de plus en
plus jeunes et la complicité d'une
partie importante de la population
ce contexte opérationnel a nécessité un
aguerrissement physique et moral
permanent des hommes et des femmes une
capacité d'entretien et de réparation de
fortune des matériels d'excellentes
performances en matière de renseignement
et le maintien d'une capacité à
surprendre l'ennemi sur un terrain qu'il
maîtrisait parfaitement dans cette
région du Sahel le sentiment
anti-français s'est développé ces
dernières années rendant l'action encore
plus difficile à conduire
ce rejet a été instrumentalisé par les
adversaires stratégiques de la France à
l'appui d'un projet d'influence
antidémocratique autoritariste
nationaliste et favorable au régime
militaire issus des putsch la commission
dresse ainsi logiquement un bilan
globalement mitigé de l'opération
barkhane l'armée française a certes été
capable de traiter les cibles identifier
mais des groupes djihadistes ont sans
cesse réapparus aucune solution
politique n'est jamais venue et une
dégradation rapide de la relation
diplomatique a pu être constaté par
ailleurs bien que le ministère des
armées est adopté une doctrine de lutte
informatique d'influence et qu'une
cellule anticipation stratégie et
orientation fonctionnent désormais au
sein de l'État major des armées la
France ne disposait que de peu de moyens
pour diffuser quotidiennement des
messages antidé information ont déploré
les rapporteurs
en outre de nombreux progrès restent à
accomplir pour que l'approche intégrée
diplomatie défense développement
atteignent son plein rendement par
exemple les actions de développement
sont restées trop centrés sur les
aspects économiques alors que les causes
des conflits sont souvent de l'ordre de
la demande de justice ou d'un égal accès
aux services publics la commission de la
défense s'attache néanmoins à relever
les nombreux enseignements tirés tout au
long de cette opération
l'efficacité de barkhane a été
progressivement améliorée des progrès
ont été réalisés dans la mise en oeuvre
des différentes fonctions
opérationnelles de nos forces armées en
contexte de conflits de haute intensité
par exemple Barka n'aura notamment
encouragé l'emploi systématique de drone
de surveillance en appui aux opérations
ainsi que la capacité à produire un
renseignement à partir d'une manœuvre
multicapteur mais cette opération
extérieure aura surtout permis une prise
de conscience de l'importance du champ
des perceptions et du champ
informationnel dans les conflits armés
les rapporteurs qui redoutent une
évolution vers des régimes de plus en
plus autoritaires et militaires dans
cette région du monde ainsi qu'un rôle
croissant des forces religieuses
fondamentalistes plaident pour un
nouveau positionnement français en
Afrique occidentale
il est souhaitable que les forces
françaises soient ainsi moins exposées
qu'au cours de la décennie écoulée
estiment-ils et un travail de
co-construction avec les partenaires
gouvernementaux s'imposent pour répondre
aux besoins exprimés si la loi de
programmation militaire prévoit une
réduction de l'effectif des bases
celle-ci doit être calibrée afin de ne
pas ôter toute capacité de réaction en
cas d'événements graves menaçant les
ressortissants français mais aussi afin
de ne pas céder le terrain aux
compétiteurs stratégiques de la France
parallèlement les auteurs du rapport
invite à revoir entièrement le
dispositif Sentinel renforcé mis en
place à partir de janvier 2015 pour
lutter contre les actes terroristes sur
le territoire français et dont
l'efficacité est discuté
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]